le Salon de l'auto de Montréal est de
retour pour 10 jours au Palais des
Congrès après une pause forcée de deux
ans évidemment raison de la pandémie
malgré l'absence de nombreux
constructeurs il y a quelques nouveautés
il y a des prototypes à faire rêver
également qui vont être représentés avec
nos surplace Benoît charrette
chroniqueur automobile rédacteur en chef
de l'Annuel de l'Automobile bonsoir
Monsieur Charette
bonsoir on voit déjà circuler près de
vous là en cette première journée est-ce
que les visiteurs étaient au rendez-vous
bon c'est une journée tranquille est-ce
qu'on doit ça à la météo il y a eu de la
neige aujourd'hui les conditions étaient
pas idéales je pense que le vrai test ça
va être demain parce que historiquement
les samedis et les dimanches sont les
grosses journées du salon de l'auto mais
il y a quand même des gens qui sont
venus qui sont présentés puis qui sont
heureux d'être là ça fait deux ans qu'on
n'est pas venu donc les gens qui sont là
vers hâte de revenir c'est un salon de
l'auto monsieur charrette qu'on pourrait
presque qualifier de modeste il y a
quelques absents qu'est-ce qui explique
le désintérêt de certaines compagnies
importantes selon vous
bon il faut dire que Montréal ne fait
pas exception à la tendance la tendance
lourde qu'on voit ailleurs les grands
salons internationaux comme Francfort
n'existe plus et maintenant à Munich le
salon de Tokyo va redevenir un salon
régional en 2023 et à travers le Canada
il y aura des salons seulement à
Montréal à Toronto et à Québec cette
année tout le reste a été retiré de
l'horaire en fait plusieurs vont dire
que pour le moment à cause des immenses
montants qu'on doit investir dans
l'électrification des modèles on a plus
vraiment d'argent à dépenser pour aller
dans des salons d'autres vont dire que
étant donné qu'il y a très peu de
véhicules de disponibles en concession
on ne veut pas investir pour vendre des
véhicules qu'on a même pas à vendre chez
soi au niveau du concessionnaire
n'empêche qu'il y a quand même 6
constructeurs qui se sont montrés
courageux et qui aussi il y en a
d'autres qui ennulés qui l'ont annoncé
très d'avance d'autres qui ont été à la
dernière minute comme c'était l'artiste
qui ont finalement annulé mais seulement
en décembre mais avec les moyens du bord
les gens du Salon de l'Auto à Montréal
ont réussi à faire quelque chose
d'intéressant et il y a des modèles qui
valent le déplacement oui des modèles
électriques entre autres monsieur
charrec sont à l'honneur on dit même que
on en présente un nombre record là pour
un événement au Canada
même chez Hyundai chez bio et que il y a
des modèles qui ont retenu votre
attention bon en fait il y a deux
concepts le concept bio et World 4 qui
est un concept très récent qu'on a vu à
peine à quelques endroits à travers le
monde qui est ici à Montréal qu'on était
chercher in extremis le modèle est
arrivé jeudi matin tout juste à temps
pour la présentation journaliste il y a
le concept seven qui est une en fait un
v.us trois rangées familiales chez
Hyundai qui est probablement un modèle
qui va ressentir le ionique 7 qui est un
modèle qui s'en vient on a aussi le ya
Nexis qu'on n'a pas encore vu sur la
route mais qu'on présente ici qui est un
coupé quatre portes très intéressant
Chevrolet a aussi plusieurs modèles bon
il y a la famille en meurtre qui attire
beaucoup la tension les gens ici dans sa
version ah ouais ah ouais c'est c'est
toujours un événement avoir en main il
est aussi
décadant dans sa version électrique qui
l'était dans sa version à essence et
beaucoup de gens m'ont parlé du
Chevrolet kinoxe et du Silverado
électrique sont ici aussi du côté de
Chevrolet bon il y a des petits nouveaux
aussi le monsieur charrette avec
l'électrification là il y a plusieurs
nouveaux noms qui sont en train de faire
leur chemin dans le marché on pense à
Vivian on pense à lucide il y avait une
face aussi présent au salon c'est
kevince qui qu'est-ce qu'on vient
présenter
c'est une jeune compagnie qui a été
fondée en 2017 au Vietnam on a commencé
au début à fabriquer des véhicules à
essence on est très vite aller vers les
véhicules électriques au moment où on se
parle on ne fabrique que des véhicules
électriques du côté de chez vinfast on a
amené ici les deux premiers modèles qui
vont être commercialisés cette année le
VF 8 et le VF neuf et on a aussi sur le
kiosque devine face le vf6 et le vf7
sont les deux prochains modèles à être
présentés qui vont arriver à partir de
2024 donc c'est des modèles 100%
électrique qui ont la particularité en
fait vinfaste offre le choix de louer sa
batterie pour une mensualité où on peut
aussi l'acheter donc ces modèles là
n'ont pas encore de concession on va
avoir des boutiques il y en a un entre
autres au carrefour de Laval ils vont en
avoir une dans la région de Québec on va
en avoir quelques-unes et on va faire un
peu comme on le fait avec
on va acheter le modèle en ligne et on
ira le chercher dans les boutiques ou
les véhicules sont présentés donc
nouveau concept qui sera à surveillé en
2023 vous avez évoqué Tesla monsieur
charrette il y a beaucoup de concurrence
dont on vient de parler d'ailleurs
plusieurs nouveaux joueurs est-ce que
c'est pour ça que Tesla a décidé de
baisser ses prix de façon importante
dernièrement
c'est une des raisons effectivement
parce que là évidemment sans que la
concurrence se rapproche parce que à
cela a eu une vision il en a ce que
malgré tout tous ces défauts ont cru
bien avant tout le monde que
l'électrification serait une réalité et
ça a largement profité à Tesla on a
établi un réseau de recharge qui n'a
encore aucun égal dans l'industrie
automobile mais là évidemment les gars
constructeurs arrivent en quantité et
avec des véhicules qui ont aussi une
qualité de haut niveau et à cela a dit
ok pourquoi ne pas baisser les prix et
ça fonctionne parce que depuis quelques
semaines la quantité de commande a
largement augmenté du côté de Tesla ça
fait le plaisir de ceux qui ont acheté
récemment mais ça met en maudit
voilà voilà alors ceux qui ont acheté il
y a un mettons un mois
ces gens-là sont un peu frustrés il y a
d'ailleurs même
de pétition qui circule une enchaîne et
une en Allemagne où on demande de
rembourser les dollars entre autres que
les gens à payer et au Canada en plus
comme le prix ABC sous la barre des
subventions fédérales mais il y a 5000
dollars de rabais à l'achat et un autre
5000 dollars de crédit parce qu'on est à
4990 dollars ce qui le place tout juste
sous la barre des 55000 dollars
admissible aux fédéral bon monsieur
charrette on aurait pu parler de plein
d'autres choses mais vous êtes au Salon
de l'auto de Montréal merci pour votre
tour d'horizon ce soir très très
apprécié
merci à une prochaine pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI